Trascrizione: Sara Mattesini
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Grazie grazie grazie per avermi aspettato.
Intanto grazie mille.
Domanda onesta, come state?
Bene, molto bene..ma io
sto meglio di voi, volete sapere perché?
Perché domani c’è il mio matrimonio,
fatemi un applauso!
[Applauso]
Grazie.
Neanche vi avessi invitato..
Grazie, grazie.
Però carini grazie mille..
Ma scherzavo e ci siete cascati!
Domani non ci sarà il mio matrimonio...
non certo perché sono single...
Cioè voglio dire, come potrei?
Grazie a chi ride,
non so come prenderla.
Domani non ci sarà il mio matrimonio
perché la persona che amo è una donna.
E in Italia nel 2021
non esistono i matrimoni egualitari,
quindi per coppie dello stesso genere.
Quindi io amo una donna non amo un uomo...
E dunque io perdo il mio diritto
ad avere il mio matrimonio.
Spettacoli dal vivo a parte,
una delle cose che mi diverte di più fare
è scrivere e creare
alcuni contenuti, video ironici per il web
in cui tratto delle tematiche sociali
che mi stanno particolarmente a cuore.
Una di queste è stata,
appunto, il matrimonio egualitario.
“Ma come non esiste?”
Mi ha commentato
un grande scrittore del web.
“Ma se ormai è pieno
di matrimoni omosessualisti in Italia!”
E un sacco di gente gli andava dietro
e commentava, erano d’accordo.
Ma no. Da una manciata di anni,
dal 2016 ci sono le unioni civili,
che non sono i matrimoni egualitari.
Avete presente un po’
quella battuta che va sul web:
“Quando lo ordini online”
e c’è,  che ne so, la foto
di Anna Marchesini, di Gigi Proietti.
E poi “quando ti arriva a casa”
e c’è la foto, che so, di Pio e Amedeo.
Insomma diciamo...
sulla mancata realizzazione
delle aspettative che ti eri fatta.
È esattamente la stessa cosa:
ti aspettavi i matrimoni,
sono arrivate le unioni civili,
che ricordiamolo sono destinate
soltanto alle coppie dello stesso genere.
Come a voler ben ribadire
che per loro la situazione sia diversa.
Ed è diversa sotto molti aspetti, non solo
come magari vi ricordate le unioni civili,
a differenza del matrimonio,
non consentono il diritto di adottare
ma, per esempio, non prevedono
neanche il vincolo di fedeltà.
E come mai non c’è il vincolo di fedeltà?
“Beh è presto detto”
- mi ha risposto sempre lui -
“perché è ovvio”
“a differenza di noi
della famiglia tradizionale”
“come possono mai essere fedeli
tra loro gli omosessualisti”
“che si sa...”
“vivono nella promiscuità,
nei glitter arcobaleno, tute in latex,”
“Strap-on in silicone
con cintura regolabile,”
“frustino in finta pelle,
gatto a nove code sadomaso,”
a soli 19,90 euro.
Alla faccia del tradizionale baby.
“scusate..
fragilità esistenziali irrisolte”
[Ride]
Ma in qualche modo il nostro amico ci
aveva preso, perché queste modifiche
sulla legge vennero fatte, appunto,
per stabilire e decretare ancora una volta
come le coppie omosessuali
non fossero valide, stabili, dignitose
quanto quelle eterosessuali.
Ma lo so che il problema è che - è vero -
una certa parte di popolazione pensa:
“Ma se noi poi” - sempre lui - “se noi poi
approviamo queste leggi poi è un attimo
che prende il potere...
la Lobby Gay
E non possiamo nemmeno immaginare
cosa potrebbe succedere poi
alla nostra nazione, ai nostri figli”.
Purtroppo però si dà il caso che,
non solo si possa immaginare
ma si possa sapere
cosa succeda a una nazione,
qualora questa approvasse una legge
per esempio come
quelle dei matrimoni egualitari
perché alcune nazioni l’hanno già fatta.
Vi dico solo per esempio quelle europee:
Austria, Belgio,
Danimarca, Finlandia, Francia,
Germania, Islanda, Irlanda, Lussemburgo,
Malta, Norvegia, Paesi Bassi, Portogallo,
Regno Unito, Spagna, Svezia,
e due settimane fa si è aggiunta
anche la Svizzera che ha detto:
“Ostrega va ben neutrale,
ma non fascista!”
[Applauso]
Ecco... Non so bene, perché...
ma per me la Svizzera
parla come mia nonna.
Ecco, siamo l’unico paese
nell’Europa occidentale
a non avere i matrimoni egualitari.
Però, ragazzi come facciamo
noi la pizza non la fa nessuno.
Eh, le priorità.
Comunque, ecco io adesso non so
se voglio un matrimonio oppure no,
ma esigo la possibilità
di poterlo avere come tutte e tutti
e come tutte e tutti,
unirmi in questo legame innaturale
che con ogni probabilità
terminerà in un salatissimo divorzio,
come tutti gli amici eterosessuali
ci insegnano dall’alto del loro 23,5%
di fallimenti coniugali.
Ecco io non so se voglio
avere figli e figlie, non lo so.
ma esigo la possibilità
di poterli avere, come tutte e tutti
e come tutti e tutti,
fare danni, creare traumi,
e garantire grande prosperità
alle future generazioni
di psicoterapeute e psicoterapeuti.
L’Italia, nella classifica
per il rispetto dei diritti umani
nei confronti delle persone LGBT+,
su 49 Stati europei,
si piazza al trentacinquesimo posto.
Neanche la Juve
di quest’anno va così male.
Oggi abbiamo parlato
molto di progresso, di chi siamo
e di chi ci stiamo preparando a diventare,
e io spero, veramente,
che questo progresso...
proprio in nome di questo progresso
si possa cominciare
a guardarsi di più intorno,
oltre che in avanti,
perché c’è il rischio che questo progresso
sia la solita scusa per
far correre più veloce le solite persone,
e far rimanere indietro le solite persone.
Una società che discrimina non è una
società che può realmente progredire.
Ora ho preparato per voi
alcune diapositive che vi possono mostrare
quali sono i dati principali in Italia
sui crimini d’odio
a matrice omobitransfobica.
Le ho preparate quindi dovrebbero anche...
Sì sì, c’è un pulsante.
Il tasto verde.
La grazia.
[Applauso]
Altra storia, devo schiacciare il rosso...
O funziona o esplode il palazzetto.
Non è esploso ma non funziona.
Non va ok ok.
.. però continuo a vedermi da lì, quindi
mi prendo in giro da sola praticamente
ma qua non funziona.
E...
Vabbè, né matrimonio né slide,
praticamente oggi è andata così.
Oggi... Niente.
Ok, va bene, oggi...
..che sicuramente... sono convinta
che se c’è qualcuno che sta commentando
online quello che sta succedendo
c’è sicuramente un “te lo meriti!”
Ma poi è bello vedere “n.you”,
no “n.you”, ho capito, “n.you”,
ma le batterie scariche magari..
nuovo, nuovo bello bello nuovo.
Vabbè molto bel-
no grazie per il supporto
[Applauso]
grazie per il supporto.
Va bene. Va beh, allora diciamo che avevo
preparato delle slide bellissime.
Evidentemente la tecnologia si ribella.
C’è un’ingerenza sul tema che
di questi tempi, diciamo che...
Veramen..
Scusate
[Applauso]
Ah ah... grazie gli applausi,
gli applausi.. grazie mille.
Ok, fantastico comunque
microfono si, slide no.
Dov’è la lobby gay quando serve,
mi viene da dire in questi casi...
Comunque...
Va beh...
Niente vedo anche l’unica cosa che va
è qua scritto “hai finito il tuo tempo”.
Molto bene...
Quindi io, senza slide,
finirò in qualche modo...
anche perché poi so che adesso magari
arriverete tardi a casa per colpa mia
e vi diranno “dove sei stato?”
“è colpa della comunità L..B...2...GW...”
quindi facciamo che... la... la...
la finiamo così.
Allora.
Quello che vi posso dire è questo.
Che in Italia si stima che ci siano
circa 4 milioni di persone LGBT+
e queste 4 milioni di persone
non hanno gli stessi diritti delle altre.
Ora questa lotta non è soltanto mia o
di queste 4 milioni di persone
ma è una lotta nostra.
Perché nostra è una società che
discrimina e non garantisce pari diritti
a tutti gli individui. E chi guardando
a una lotta tra oppressori e oppressi
decide di non schierarsi,
mi dispiace,
ma è anch’esso oppressore,
perché non esiste la neutralità
in materia di discriminazione.
Quindi... Questa sera, in questi minuti,
siete stati con me mi avete supportato,
mi avete applaudito,
mi avete aiutato.
Credendo che qualcosa non funzionasse.
Beh... Ora vi prego di farlo
ma per qualcosa che davvero non funziona.
Non di certo per questo telecomando e
proiettore che hanno sempre funzionato.
Siamo in teatro signori miei,
non in Parlamento.
[“Adesso diamoci da fare, eh”]
Grazie.